So now's the time to put in your bed for the name for element
117.
I think it would be really good to name an element after Richard Fineman.
So you could have the element find Manian with the
element symbol. I think F Y would be quite nice.
I'm particularly excited about element 117.
You mind tell us why,
but 117 was the only element in the periodic table.
When we started this project, when nobody had even seen one atom,
it's never been observed in any form at all.
So the field's way wide open.
And I thought that it would be quite impossible to make a video.
When we were making videos about each element about an element when nobody had
even seen one atom,
this arrangement just seems to fall to bits before it can properly form.
Then about three years ago, our first video wasn't very good.
There was an exciting result from Russia,
from [inaudible] where they synthesized the first
atoms of element 117.
No, no, it's really exciting because it's, it's,
it's the generation of new matter. You know,
it's almost like a chill goes up your spine. It's like, wow, something new,
something really exciting.
Those of you who've watched our videos for a long time will know that if you
want to synthesize a new element and have your experiments
accepted, you have to wait until somebody else has repeated the experiments,
done it a different way and got the same result. Otherwise anybody could say,
Oh, I've seen an atom of elements. So-and-so in fact,
there has been the case with element 118,
where somebody did cheat and the first results were wrong
and were faked. I've explained several times,
and you may have seen some of the videos, how you make these elements.
You take a sample of a really quite heavy element and the heavier the better,
and then bombard it with atoms of a lighter element,
which you accelerate really fast after days.
Perhaps they stick together and you make a big
atom. In the case of elements, 117,
you choose elements where the atomic numbers,
when you add them together, add up to 117. In this case,
they used an element 97,
but helium and calcium,
which is element number 2020 plus 97 makes 117.
And the atoms of calcium were accelerated in a huge accelerator in
Germany at the GSI in dumb start to speed. That's about a 10th,
the speed of light and banged into the sound pool of berkelium and
created a few atoms.
Now the technical problem is that berkelium itself is a highly
radioactive and unstable element and in a very productive
demonstration of international collaboration,
the berkelium was made in America in the Oak Ridge
national lab, and then 13 milligrams.
That's a tiny bit,
just almost too small to see just a few
grains were transported to Germany in order to do
this, you can't just have a lump of berkelium.
You have to have one particular isotope,
a single mass of berkelium.
They had the berkelium two 49 and this sample was
transported to Germany and it's radioactive.
It has a half-life of 330 days.
So it means every 330 days half of it, the K's away.
So not only is it radioactive, but you will have to work quite quickly.
All your valuable sample is gone before you get round to doing the experiment.
So they did the experiment.
The berkelium was made in the Oak Ridge national lab transported to Germany,
and then it was bombarded with calcium atoms
and they looked for the signals for the decay of element
117.
And they sold signals corresponding to the sorts of decays that are here on my
tie from earlier radioactive elements they've made.
And the way these elements decay is that they give off alpha particles.
These are nuclear ive, helium atoms,
and the mass changes in steps of four.
So the mass goes down by four units and it transforms one element
into another. And in fact,
they discovered some quite interesting isotopes of other elements that were
formed, which had never been observed before during this decay.
Kelly, Ms. Such a pain in the backside, and I have to get this tiny sample,
which decays away. Why not let you use different elements?
Why did they use 50 and 67?
I think the reason that they use these pretty light atoms is that if they get
used bigger than bigger atoms for the collision,
there's a likelihood that everything will smash up because the smaller elements
are inherently stronger and they don't fragment when they hit the targets.
And so I think if you used, um,
57 and 60,
you just end up with a fantastic mess of fragments going everywhere.
You might make the old datum of 117,
but it would be lost in the noise with everything else.
So the next is the to committee joint committee of the
international union of pure and applied chemistry. And the corresponding,
one of physics has to decide whether the evidence is really good enough.
If everybody's happy, then there's the exciting thing.
They choose the name for the element,
the people who get the honor,
those that discover the element originally.
I'm not sure whether this will be counted as the Russians or the
Germans, but I suspect that everybody will sit down together.
And there was a huge team working on the latest project.
I think more than 70 scientists from all sorts of different countries.
And so now I'm going to put in my bit,
I think it would be really good to name an element after Richard Fineman,
who was a physicist who worked on the Manhattan project.
So he has connections with the Oak Ridge lamp where the berkelium was
married,
but he's also a huge figure in modern nanotechnology
and a founder of much of the research that is being done now.
So you could have the element find Manian with the
element symbol. I think F Y would be quite nice. Um,
and that would also serve another purpose because when you see Fireman's name
written down,
a lot of people are not sure whether you should pronounce it Fineman or Feynman,
but if the element symbol is F Y they will all know it has to be pronounced
fine. So my bid for this name is find my name.
A group of Russians and Germans.
Aren't going to name it after an American though, are they?
I think it's quite possible that they would,
because after all the Germans named element
112 after Copernicus who was Polish,
and I think we have got to the stage now where elements are being
named after figures or places that have a world
role and nationalism is going
away.
And I certainly think that anybody who's write anything
about Fineman could imagine that he was a typical
citizen of any country. He is about the most unconventional,
the scientist that is lived in the last hundred years and also
one of the really influential ones as well.
The professor for the last year or two though,
I've heard you advocating the name plank diem. We still haven't got Planky. Um,
have you, have you abandoned your love of the idea of plank Hill?
I still like the name plank, Tim,
but there's another element still hundred and 1,513.
So there's still, um, opportunities and of course, 118 as well,
but hundreds and 17 is an odd number and it's good to name an
odd element. After an old scientist.
I've already got the prize. The prize is the pleasure of finding the thing out,
the kick and the discovery, the observation other people use it.
Those are the real things. The honors are unreal to me.
I don't believe in honors.